any gamuts i should be sure to decline
one gambit comes to mind actually
um i forget the name of it
me chess will know it's something i've i
probably never played it's a gambit you
can play as black
uh let's look at the somali chess
and black plays this move
it's called the shilling caustic gambit
where black is gaming this pawn
and this is something if you take the
pawn then like white's already in big
trouble
and it's a really cool trap i'm sure
some people have have seen this before
and we can see based on the stats like
if if white takes the pawn black is
winning 77 percent of the time
white's better off taking the knights so
to show the trap after takes
uh there's a really nice move queen g5
sacking even more material
let's say white takes and forks we take
on
g2 attacking the rook after rook f1 we
take on e4
and then after bishop e2 we deliver mate
so it's a very easy way to to win
quickly
i think most
most players won't fall for this but
there's some
there's probably some group of like
beginner players that just play
like italian and would easily stumble
into this
so it's a drop to try we can check on
only chess
[Music]
oh let me oh that's funny i had my
filter settings off
i only was looking at games with a 2500
rated player
i am just in time for the greatest
explanation
awesome yeah welcome back holy rove
oh so maybe this could be one of the
most common opening traps
on all of lychas or maybe all of chess
in general
knight takes e5 queen g5
okay bishop f7 played more often but
okay we can look into that move later
knight f7 played 12 000 times
wow so over 7
000 people got to this position
man there's a lot of people not finding
the maiden one
okay this is still winning but that's
this is a nice way to to finish off a
game
just to show bishop f7 because i think
it's still good for black
even though white has initiative the
king has to move
you uh you can delay reverse spawn cloud
king e7
and then this is attacked this is always
pressured
and the pawn is still hanging so
i imagine i imagine black's better here
oh white's better
white's white's better after sacking a
piece so
castling takes
okay it's unclear stockfish
yeah stockfish doesn't know
like black's up a piece here but
white's having initiative because the
king's on e7
f4 is coming these pieces are a bit
awkward
like c3 d4 also coming
so yeah black still wins the majority of
the games
anyway yeah hopefully people learn
something i know people are are very
thirsty for
maybe lesser known newer opening traps
given that everyone's learning the
staffer these days